I would love someone else when they see
it and not only say it's beautiful,
but hopefully to say that
the experience went beyond that.
I mean,
because beauty in the art world
particularly let's say in the,
in the kind of academic world is,
is a dismissive term,
which,
uh,
essentially would mean a decorative.
And I
say to students,
I say,
well,
I hate to tell you guys,
but you could make it as rigorous as you
want.
You can make it as theoretical as you
want,
but
don't make it that hermetic.
Let other people in,
you know,
remember,
who are you talking to?
You just want to talk to yourself.
You want to talk to a few art
professionals or as Barnett Newman said,
do you want to hit the ball out of the
field?
I think that's really important.
I think that is a really important part
of being an artist.
You know,
I always had a sense of
who I was talking to
in my work,
who my audience was.
It was always very limited.
It's the voices in our head.
We all have voices in our head and
that's what I mean by the kind of,
uh,
the weight of consciousness,
who those voices are,
how they change over the years.
They change sometimes in my head,
those voices a matter of fact,
most of the time,
unfortunately those voices are very
harsh.
They say render really,
um,
very astringent criticism.
Know which any artist will tell you that
they're there.
They're their own worst critic.
I don't have to read criticism to know
everything that's wrong with my work.
Does not,
never a critic who said something bad
about my work that I didn't disagree,
that I disagreed with
because I knew when I read it
that I could do it better.
As a matter of fact,
when I've read good things,
it kind of upsets me.
I don't know why.
It's just the way I am.
When you're talking to students,
you tell them,
you know,
when the end,
you can do whatever you want,
but,
but don't let these terms and don't let
the,
the academic part of being an artist,
the kind of graduate mentality,
the graduate school,
uh,
oppress you because that's exactly why
you became an artist.
You know,
it's kind of a peeling back of layers.
It's,
it's hopefully a path to some kind of,
some kind of liberation,
uh,
some kind of map of how you could find
your way out of the,
what I consider the unnecessary
suffering
that goes on in a lot of our minds all
the time.